And sexual selection is no joke.
It could be the primary thing.
It's certainly one of the primary things that's driven human evolution.
And I think you can say that
you think about the environment again,
let's think about the environment.
So you have a dominance hierarchy and that's really an old structure.
The dominance is harkeys 300 million years old because it emerged pretty much
whenever there was,
whenever there was a nervous system,
emergent nervous system,
and whenever animals had occupied the same territory,
they automatically organize themselves into something approximating a dominance
hierarchy.
So it's a very,
very,
very old structure.
It's older than trees,
it's older than flowers,
it's old.
And as far as real goes,
from a Darwinian sense,
permanent is real.
And so when you,
you can say,
well,
you know,
our burial ancestors adapted themselves to treats.
And so the tree was a long,
around long enough to be a feature of the environment.
But the dominance hierarchy has been around a lot longer than trees.
And you can think of the dominance hierarchy both as an adaptation to the
environment,
because you'd kind of think about the dominant Turkey has a cultural construct,
but if a cultural construct lasts long enough,
then it becomes part of the environment.
And so the dominant Turkey's part of the environment.
And what seems to happen roughly speaking,
and this is an oversimplification,
but we'll go with it,
is that males have a dominance hierarchy and there's a relatively small number
of males that are relatively successful.
And those successful males have preferential access to female reproductive
capacity,
either because of the females actively choose the more dominant males,
which is very,
very common.
Or because the more dominant males chase all the less dominant males away so
that even if the females don't exercise choice,
which they often do,
then the only males left around that can serve as reasonable mating partners are
the more powerful ones.
And so you think you got to really radical determiners of evolution as a
consequence of that one?
Is that
each,
I'm not talking about female dominance hierarchies at the moment,
but I can talk about that.
But that's why this is an oversimplification,
but what happens is that the males obviously are selected for their ability to
move up dominance hierarchies obviously because the ones that are at the top of
the dominance hierarchy reproduce preferentially.
And so that means the male dominance hierarchy becomes a method of selection.
But then allied with that is the female proclivity for choice on whatever
dimension the dominance hierarchy happens to be arranged.
And so then female sexual selection also becomes a radical nonrandom selector
of,
of what,
what genetic material is to move into the next generation.
And so I,
I fail to see how any of that can be separated from the emergence of complex
nervous systems and mind over the course of evolution because people aren't,
creatures aren't making random choices,
they're not random at all.
So we even notice it.
Such things like managing the Peacock's tail,
you know,
and it's covered with eyes,
which is quite interesting because eyes of course attract attention and lots of
animals have evolved.
I light markings like Moss,
there's moss that when they unfold their wings,
they have two big eyes on the back of them.
And that's to keep birds from eating them.
Right?
Cause the birds don't like being stared at.
So they stay away from the moths.
But so a peacock's tail is nothing but eyes.
And so it's very attractive and it shimmers and there's something about it
that's beautiful,
which is quite interesting to the females have obviously been selecting the male
peacock peacocks for beauty.
They have this insane tail while so they,
evolutionary biologists have thought,
well what possible utility could that tail be?
Is it just maybe the females got fixated on tail so to speak.
And you know,
you got a Baldwin effect loop going there and the male peacocks just got bigger
and bigger tales and it's just like an evolutionary dead end.
It's,
you know,
it's a positive feedback list system that's gone out of control.
But they have done things that like look at the symmetry and,
and,
and breadth say,
or the symmetry and size and overall quality of the male peacock's tail as a
marker for physical health.
So reduce parasite load for example.
And it does turn out that the healthier male peacocks have better tail display.
And so the way,
what the females seem to be doing is using some marker or some set of markers as
a proxy indicator for,
for,
for health.
And I think,
I think you could say with,
with reasonable,
you could say reasonable that reasonably that female human beings do the same
thing to male human beings.
And there's some of that vice versa too.
Like we evaluate each other,
for example,
for symmetry,
which is one of the elements of beauty because healthier people tend to be more
symmetrical and lots of animals use symmetry.
Butterflies if butterflies won't mate with another butterfly,
if it deviates from symmetry by the tiniest amounts,
you can imagine.
So symmetry is a marker and there's other markers like shoulder width to waste
with his wanton waste,
with to hip with this is another,
that's usually what males use that to evaluate females in park.
So there's lots of markers of health.
Um,
but it also looks to me like the,
the,
the data worldwide seems to indicate that women,
so managing that women May to cross dominance hierarchies and up
socioeconomically speaking and on average across cultures,
women go for men who are about four to five years older.
You know,
it varies.
In the Scandinavian countries that's shrunk a little bit,
but not that much.
And in other cultures it's bigger.
I would say that depends to some degree on difficulty of establishing economic
independence,
right?
Because in richer countries it's easier to have enough economic independence if
you're a male to B to B are useful participant in the process of having
children.
Um,
but it doesn't matter cross culturally,
it's still across an op where man mate across and down,
they don't care much about socioeconomic status.
It doesn't seem to be part of their selection method.
Um,
generally speaking.
So,
so I think that part of that is also that the ability of women to select for
male health,
it's something like that because it isn't the only that,
because if you're healthy and energetic,
you're much more likely to be successful because it's very hard to be successful
if you're ill,
obviously.
I mean,
so because the competition is just too high.
And both,
both genders,
both sexes select each other for attractiveness,
both select for intelligence,
both at select for personality,
although the different,
there are differences there in terms of what's what stressed.
But so,
so,
so I think you can derive a couple of things out of out of this.
And this is where I think people are different than,
than other animals.
Importantly different is that,
so you imagine that there's tremendous selection pressure to,
uh,
towards the production,
let's say of man who are good at climbing male dominance hierarchies or climbing
the male dominance hierarchy.
But the thing that's so interesting about people is that we've multiplied our
dominance hierarchies.
You know,
if you take an animal that's got a rather static behavioral pattern,
then there's,
there's the single hierarchy.
Elephant seals are a good example of that.
So elephant seals,
the males are absolutely massive.
They're way,
way bigger than the females.
And they basically have harems roughly speaking,
and they use physical prowess as their marker of status essentially.
And obviously size is a huge part of that because otherwise the male elephant
seals wouldn't be as,
they're massive.
These things are absolutely enormous.
And so it's just power slash health,
you know,
maybe aggression,
something like that.
It's whatever makes them more um,
suitable for the kind of physical combat that elephant seals engage it.
So,
and the degree to which power is associated with dominance status in those sorts
of situations seems to be associated with the size differential between males
and females.
So the more power is an issue with regards to male competence,
the larger the bales are compared to the females and the more likely the males
are going to have a harem relationship with the females.
And you see that a little bit in human beings because men are bigger than women.
They're not overwhelmingly bigger.
That's sexual dimorphism.
And you know,
there's some men that are smaller than some women,
but on average men are tolerant there.
They have more upper body strength and so forth.
So there is a power element to male competition,
but it's not as extended as it would be among animals say like,
like elephant seals.
So in the elephant seal you see maybe there's one stable set of traits that's
being selected for that makes the males more likely to reproduce.
But human beings,
we're very weird creatures because we're so conceptually flexible.
And so what seems to have happened,
maybe we started males started selecting each other for don in dominance
competitions for something like cognitive flexibility and conscientiousness.
It's something like that.
So that would be the ability to abstractly represent the world and then the
ability operate effectively within it to represent yourself socially in a way.
And then to carry through with that because that enables people to trust you.
So it's something like that.
And so that produced cortical expansion and then women were selecting men who
are good at that and not produce cortical expansion.
And then there's an arms race between women and men with regards to
intelligence.
So the women kept up or they certainly kept up with,
with,
with intelligence as,
as the evolutionary cycle continued.
But one of the consequences of selection for cortical expansion and increased
cognitive flexibility was that the number of dominance hierarchies that human
beings could produce started to multiply,
right?
Because there's all sorts of ways that you can be successful.
There's,
you think about how many ways you can be successful in a modern culture,
and you can be successful in dimensions that aren't even associated with each
other.
So you can be successful socially that that's what an extrovert would do.
You could be successful in terms of intimate relationships.
That's what a agreeable person would do.
A disagreeable person would be more successful with regards to competition.
A person who is high in neuroticism would be,
would be tried to protect themselves and to establish some sort of security and
open person would be looking for a flexible,
creative environment.
And so there's this multiplicity of,
of ways that you can establish a dominance hierarchy and be successful in it.
And if you're creative,
you can come up with your own damn dominance hierarchy,
which is exactly what you're doing.
If you're creative,
right?
You,
you spin up a game that's your game and then you,
you make the rules.
And that's hard because if you make a new game with new rule,
if it's hard to monetize it,
but you can be the best at playing that game.
And so that's a huge advantage to being creative if you can pull it off.
So then you think,
well,
what's happened among human beings is the multiplication of the set of possible
dominance hierarchies.
So it's become very broad.
And then you could say,
well,
what's,
what's driving selection now is the ability to be successful across multiple
sets of dominance hierarchies.
And that account's at least in part for our cognitive flexibility.
And so that's really what a human being is.
A human being is a creature that has high potential for succeeding across a very
wide range of potential human dominance hierarchies.
And so that gives us our transformative psyche.
That's the niche,
that's the niche that we've both produced and occupy.
And I think it's out of that,
that hero mythology emerges fundamentally because I think what the hero is,
the mythological hero is a representation of that part of the psyche that's
particularly good at being successful across sets of dominance hierarchies.